Like so many concepts with refinement necessary in sufficient conditions, for
typical concepts in typical conditions, what about exemplar concepts?
Exemplar concepts don't even have typical conditions, let alone necessary and
sufficient conditions. In case of exemplar concepts, I can give you examples.
Perhaps I can do some implicit abstraction of some examples, but
it's about as far as I can go. Consider the example of beauty for a second.
There are four examples of something beautiful. Here's a painting by Van Gogh,
here's a beautiful sunset, a beautiful flower, a beautiful dance and
so on. While I can give examples of the concept of beauty,
it's really hard to come up with the typical condition of a beauty.
Exemplar concepts are very hard to, define. And for that reason, they
are also very hard to, communicate to each other, or to teach in a art program.
Exemplar concepts can be culture specific, sometimes even individual specific.